hey if you want to get some epic anime
merch that you're not gonna find
anywhere else check out our online store
anime out Broadcom we have Eskin or
praise the Sun Mele Otis feel the wrath
bond love the pain more esken or more
Mele Otis and other things too so check
us out link in the description what is
up everybody its Anna Mac here for anime
uproar and today I will be talking about
SK Knorr brand new form SK Knorr
ultimate form which allowed him to
maintain the power of the one beyond
just one minute and it appears that s
Kannur was even able to enhance the
power of the one through this new form
referred to as the one ultimate or the
ultimate one but even though this new
ultimate s kannur is the ultimate badass
warrior who managed to stand against the
demon king and even get the upper hand
much the demon king surprise and
frustration I have to emphasize that
it's not all good news for Eska nor in
chapter 3 to 8 we learned the truth
about the source of a scanners new power
and the tragic consequences of his
decision to use it I will be addressing
all of that right here in this video so
let's get into the action and the drama
right now if you enjoyed the seven
deadly sins content on this channel and
you want to see more please leave a like
to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar over get subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications the brand new season of
the seven deadly sins anime is now
airing in Japan we will be keeping you
updated on all the latest news and
updates surrounding the new anime season
including when it will be available
outside of Japan so please if you want
to learn more follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar and we will
keep you posted there finally this video
will contain manga spoilers I'm gonna be
talking about the latest developments in
the story so please proceed with caution
you have been warned in Chapter three to
eight we pick up where chapter three to
seven left off with Eska nor somehow
being able to maintain the power of the
one beyond one minute by attaining a
brand new
form a bigger badder and even more
powerful form known as the one ultimate
the form itself looks absolutely epic
Big Daddy sunshine has ascended beyond
mere praise the Sun re2 the status of a
living legend a walking talking
supernova as epic as eScan or normally
is and especially in the one form this
ultimate esken or is on a whole other
level we may have to get yet another
esken or shirt design going at Annamayya
Broadcom an ultimate Eskin or shirt if
that's something you'd like to see in
the future and if that's something that
you would wear leave a hashtag ultimate
askin or down in the comments to let me
know the other sins are shocked that
Eskin or was somehow able to maintain
the one for longer than a minute and
even the demon king is feeling the heat
the demon king is unable to pull his
fist out of Eskin oars ultimate manly
abs and as a result s can or get some
quality punches in on the demon king
Mele Otis finally explains that this new
power that s Connor is using is not the
result of sunshine alone which of course
is Eskin or special ability that was
once a divine grace belonging to Miele
the strongest of the four Archangels we
are all familiar with sunshine but this
is not just sunshine alone instead as I
had speculated in my two most recent
seven deadly sins videos s canora's
boosting his sunshine abilities even
further by converting his own life
energy into magic to put it simply s
canora's planning to use up all of his
life energy in order to defeat the demon
king this is exactly what I was afraid
of and I mentioned this multiple times
in previous videos s canora's planning
to sacrifice his life during this battle
in order to protect his friends and
spare them from having to risk their own
lives in a deadly battle against the
demon king s Kannur wants to take all of
the burden and all of the risk onto
himself and sacrifice his life to ensure
the safety of everyone else the other
sins all look extremely worried at this
point even Merlin known for usually
being stoic and unaffected by the things
happening around her is visibly
concerned this was definitely a touching
moment for me
as I was reading this chapter you guys
know that I ship s Kannur and Merlin
forever so this confirmation that s
Connor is going to sacrifice his life
coupled with that grave expression on
Merlin's face really gave me the fields
s Kannur demonstrates incredible
unbelievable strength power and
determination in this new ultimate form
he actually manages to get the upper
hand on the demon king and to beat him
back
however the demon king is by no means
defeated and he continues to fight a
second or this time with long-range
attacks at that point meliodas king and
bond are compelled to interfere in order
to help Eskin or avoid the demon King's
attacks and they also launched a few
attacks of their own against the demon
king but s kannur isn't having any of
that he repeats that he doesn't want the
sense to interfere because he intends to
defeat the demon king on his own s
Kannur is determined to do it on his own
because he wants to be the only one who
has to suffer and the only one who has
to die he wants to take all the
sacrifice onto himself so that his
friends don't have to suffer however
malleolus has had enough and he even
asks as Kannur what are you doing idiot
Mele Otis says that if s Connor wants
him to move out of the way and let him
continue to fight on his own s Kannur
will have to for smelly old us out of
the way himself Mele Otis proclaims that
he didn't invite s Couture to join the
seven deadly sins just so a scanner
could act out like this and so that he
could sacrifice his own life so easily
s cano responds by reminding me Leodis
and the rest of the sense how much they
helped him in his life including all the
effort they put in to help him learn to
control his power s Kannur who before
joining the seven deadly sins was
incredibly lonely and depressed asks
meliodas
and the sins if they have any idea how
happy that made him feel back then s
Kannur was a young lonely insecure and
depressed boy who was terrified of his
own power but the sins took him in they
helped him and they made him a member of
their close-knit group when everyone
else was afraid of s Kannur when
everyone else considered s kannur to be
a dangerous monster the sins took him in
and made him a member of their family
this meant everything to s Kannur and he
feels that he owes his life to them so
he will not hesitate to sacrifice his
life in order to
protect his friends co-author tells us
Kannur that yes the sins do know how
much they mean to him but there is no
more time for chatting because in the
very next moment the demon king summons
a creature of darkness a massive demonic
monster with all sorts of different
appendages including arms insect legs
and tentacles the monster begins
attacking the sins and Eskin or rushes
to face off against the creature s
Connor says that all this time he held
one promise in his heart that promise
was that his life the life that he was
once ready to abandon would instead be
sacrificed for the sake of all his
friends the seven deadly sins but it is
clear from the expression on their faces
that the sins do not want Eskin or to
sacrifice his life they appreciate his
love for them and his commitment to
their friendship they are touched by how
much they mean to him but they don't
want him to throw away his life either
as s Connor attempts to get to the giant
demonic creature first Meli otis beats
him to it malli otis says that if s
Kenard intends to put his life on the
line for them then it only makes sense
that they would do the same for him s
Kannur sees that all the sins including
king merlin goal thir bond and the N are
rushing in to help they are rushing to
fight the giant demon monster and the
demon king himself together with s
Kannur the seven deadly sins all working
together as a team
smashed a demon monster to the demon
king shocked and surprised but in the
next moment s Kannur addresses all of
the sins directly and he tells them that
it's too late for him to turn back now
because of that he has an order for all
of them he asks them to let him fight
alongside them so that they can all be
together as friends to the very end the
final two pages of chapter three to
eight clearly implied that s Kannur has
already gone beyond the point of no
return that he has used up too much of
his life energy already it is implied
that it is already too late and that s
Kannur is going to die regardless so he
wants to put in one last grand effort in
this battle against the demon king
before his body gives out and he dies
all the sins look incredibly sad Mele
Otis even has to wipe tears away from
his eyes as the
agrees to fight together with Eska nor
to the end on the final page this battle
is referred to as the final battle for
the seven deadly sins and there is a
strong indication that s Kannur is about
to meet his tragic end if this really is
the case it will be a truly sad
although noble end for s kannur but
let's not jump to conclusions just yet
because the manga has definitely psyched
us out in the past so just because this
battle has been referred to as the final
battle doesn't mean that it really is
the final battle and just because it has
been implied that s Kannur may died
doesn't mean that he really will die
after everything is said and done don't
forget what I said months ago we are
still going to see Arthur and Excalibur
make an appearance I am confident that
we haven't seen the last of them even
though Arthur is supposed to be dead so
the idea that s Connor will die and
there will be no way to bring him back
to life is definitely premature at this
point we'll have to wait and see what
happens
but I know enough about this manga and
about knockabout Suzuki not to make any
definitive predictions about how and
when this story will end the next
chapter chapter 3 to 9 is being billed
as a battle between the demon king and
self drous so it is fair to assume that
in chapter 3 - 9 the focus will return
to the inside of Zelda's soul where the
battle for control of Zelda's body is
being waged between him and gelda on the
one side and the demon king on the other
we always knew that just like with the
previous battle against the demon king
back when he was possessing the body of
meli otis this battle would have to be
waged on two separate fronts on the
inside and on the outside at first his
ljus was unconscious on the inside and
the demon king was doing a good job of
keeping him docile but now the vampire
waifu gelda is in there with zelgius and
from what we know about her so far she
is not the type of woman to accept the
demon King's control of her beloved's
body we can expect a harsh battle to
rage between sell dress and gelda versus
the demon king on the inside Walter
battle between the demon king and all
seven of the seven deadly sins also
rages at the same time on the outside
things are really speeding up and
heating up and unless something drastic
happens this battle could be resolved in
the next
few chapters but even if this battle is
resolved will it really be the final
battle or are we still in for more
surprises from the supreme deity as I
said earlier I expect that we still
haven't seen the last of Arthur an
Excalibur and I am certain that we
haven't seen the last of hawk and the
mother of chaos so we might still get
yet another showdown over in purgatory
at some point in the near future let me
know what you guys think is Eskin or
really dying or will knock up a Suzuki
find a way to save him and is this
battle really ending or are we still in
for more twists and turns let me know
down in the comments you know I always
love hearing from you if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell don't forget to follow
us on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest 7 Deadly Sins
news and updates including news and
updates about the new anime series I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our animal / patrons for making videos
like this one possible special thank you
to all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
eldress on hell cruise stealers poet
Pablo
atropos Rey $30 beat karate en Anatole
Cosette's ki and Lord Albert and of
course some massive thank you to all of
our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
Ingrid ah a Lola madam madam AK
makoto-kun and yaboy seth if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron only discord and to show our
gratitude your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
Cowboys
[Music]